okay so you guys are arguing about body
count why before the show
so yeah they they came in and apparently
I wasn't here for this conversation but
the guests wait in the lobby before they
come up because you know we don't want
to be going up and down it's a long
elevator ride and then I guess in the
lobby there's a conversation about body
count that was had
so what what did I miss fill me in I
missed it so
no um he's basically saying that
what was you saying again it was just
waffle simple body count matter and you
don't believe it does I never said that
I don't believe you okay he was playing
there exactly so what was you saying so
the reason body count matters is because
I didn't realize especially until I
probably watch a lot of your content and
I spoke to a lot of other girls that it
was that sire
no
um yeah that that this many girls like
were like oh body count doesn't matter
because I was like as far as we knew
body count always maximum and I don't
know if you ever didn't have a mom that
didn't love you or Dad wasn't around or
you don't have any brothers because if
you did you would have known that that
that that is is precious that is sacred
and the moment you start giving it out
and the moment you start doing that it
cheapens your value so the fact that
girls think that and and and nothing I
always say is like when you ask a girl
what's a body count
she's gonna lie or she's gonna tell you
the truth once and then when she says it
to a guy that she really likes and he
doesn't like what he hears and he
disappears from that moment on she's
gonna start lying
um
what do you guys think
my thing is yeah I do I understand your
point where he said oh but he can't does
matter yeah that's fair enough but
why do you want to know
what okay so let's say for instance you
meet again her body can't smoke all
right come on let's go you made a body
cut um a girl and a body count is like
say six or something or even ten why
does that now why does that affect your
potential obviously you're saying you
know there's those ghosts of Christmas
Past and men's past yeah that stuff
but comparison is a thief of Joy right
so
like initially
initially for us what we want we wanted
the Virgin so what for in reality one
body's too many but nowadays like that
Pearl will say we're praying for under
five bodies right because the girls that
were the girls that were meeting now 10
20 30 40 as you get older the bodies
will keep no but your face is like that
but how do you think we feel we feel we
thought we feel like that yeah because
historically men had to ensure paternity
so it's like we may live in a modern era
but it doesn't undo their wiring and
their their predisposition to be
disgusted by by a girl that's a hoe
because historically they didn't know if
that kid was theirs so they could be
passing on their resources and their
time and their energy into a kid that's
not even theirs
and then on top of that like if you've
slept
um if a girl's a virgin she's an 80
chance of a happy marriage after 10
years where if she slept with more than
five people it drops down to 30 percent
which I think most guys would pray for
nowadays but that's because they don't
know good sex because the guy has
nothing to compare or the woman doesn't
happen yeah but why do why do we want
why would you like why would you want to
compare someone to your husband
like what what good does that do you if
you're telling me that I don't know good
sex what you're also saying to me I'm
not no no not like that not me
personally but when you're saying that
in order for to no good sex a woman has
to have multiple partners then you're
just saying to us you're being run
through no not multiple partners I'm
saying like the how would you the
marriage no the marriage is obviously
going to be better because you don't
know any better yeah but that's right
that's good
I'm not arguing against it because
because imagine this right yeah like you
you're like I don't know any better but
it could be better but I don't know it's
better but what if it is now you're
living in that what if but you actually
have something really good that's there
right and that so if you're slept with
if you're slept with 20 guys for example
right yeah they'll say it doesn't matter
but if I'm the 21st guy I'm now
comparing to 20 other guys like
different sizes different sexual
techniques now I might be good or
whatever but what are the chances are
that after 20 guys that at the 21st guy
I'm gonna be able to be the one that
does it for you well yeah I agree
the point and how many
girls have an ex they can't get over or
you know you know damn well that girl is
with that guy but she doesn't want him
that's like every guy's worst fear
because guys are like they don't know
um like they don't know the difference
because girls or girls can play a part
easy
who are you thinking of I can see it in
your eyes
yeah what are you thinking of
no but like
it wasn't because like okay in that
example yeah like which one you tell me
names
because that's the thing though like
let's say like I can now meet you yeah
you may not have had like let's say my
body count is 20 God forbid
um
no way but let's say is that like I've
met you I've now I've now had Tyrone
with the nine line the the or whatever
nobody wants that let's be honest but
like less but now I'm now looking at you
for your personality because I've been
there done that had that
do you know I mean like I'm now looking
for the the other qualities in you yeah
but like so it's that's they talk about
it in the rational mail where it's like
the Alpha and the beta so you're looking
for a provider you're looking for a more
stable Guy where you're looking for the
hot guy to begin with yeah he can do and
he can't do anything yeah but like a
part of you is still gonna want that
depending on where you are in your cycle
so like I don't remember exactly where
it's at but like you you crave different
traits based on where you are in your
cycle and so when you I think so I think
it's like when you're ovulating you
start to Crave like more of the like
super hot guy not me where am I not in
my life I prefer but uh
um I prefer the the man that is let's
say like not as sexually as experienced
because um jobless men have yeah sex
right because jobless men can hear that
yeah but but that's that's the point
like most guys don't want to be the guy
you want to be like stable what they
want they want to be the guy that you're
like super hot for like that you that
you just find him so stupid attractive
but like once you've had that level of
guy you can't find that level of guy
that stupid attractive anymore and
that's why that's why I raise it that's
right they always um talk about it's not
necessarily about the number of bodies
it's like the quality it's it's a weird
concept but it's like basically like she
might have slept with five people but if
one of them was I don't even know who
Jason Momoa is but apparently he's a
really attractive I like seriously don't
know who he is but that's the example
no I don't really watch movies so I
don't I watch YouTube it's really big
yeah good but if he one of them is Jason
Momoa it's like that girl's ruined for a
lifetime because she's always going to
want Jason Momo who comes after that
even I was thinking about this the other
day Blake Lively seems so so wifey but
she's still Leonardo DiCaprio's
leftovers so Ryan Ryan Reynolds is with
her now
who does she really want I didn't even
remember that Leonardo and Blake like
yeah like five years or something and so
it's not necessarily about the number
but like as he was saying if it's 20
what are the odds that you're the best
out of 20. yeah but Jason there's a
reason why Jason Momoa is no longer
there
I don't I don't know who he is look I
just think I I think it's a lot for a
man to be putting on the line right and
I just think as men you're not coming to
us with virginity so we're already not
coming with that a lot of times then
you're coming with with with other extra
stuff so these little these little
things that we're asking for is because
we're quite aware that once a woman has
had that what do you call it um Alpha
Widow don't you call it is that what
you've um you call it album once a
girl's been Alpha widowed it's like
you're coming as the guy after that and
it's never going to be good for that and
we've seen it even if she gets in a
long-term relationship she'll end up
being back outside at some point because
unless she's truly truly want to change
a life background you know I mean but
most times Once A girl has a girl has
experienced something they want to go
back to that and it's just unfortunate
that that that you know there's gonna be
some poor guy that's gonna be the end of
it but that's how the game goes do you
think that's boys here do you think it's
like an ego thing between us like we
don't want our girl to be sleeping
around with oh well no man should be
able to tell you what your woman looks
like naked this is what yeah this is
what I'm trying to say though this is we
don't want we don't want a girl that has
slept with three people from the area or
or two we prefer innocence but we don't
want that as well
yeah yeah yeah
all the girls that are sleeping with
Drake are super concerned about all the
bodies but this is what I mean Paul
because they say but then all these boys
that have sleep with 40 girls 50 girls
how on Earth do they get there how how
because men and women are not the same
this is exactly what I'm trying to say
no because end of the day like let's
let's be real right
so so some goals are going to say a man
that slept before him I'll never ever
touch him oh he's disgusting but no
someone know some girls who will purely
detest them but most girls they're gonna
be like raw especially if the women are
high quality let's talk about the types
of women if these are high quality women
most women are going to be attracted by
the fact that this man has slept with 40
High School women that they consider to
be threats and as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible